alors c'était l'occasion ou jamais de
donner sa chance à un jeune vous avez
voulu faire voilà j'avais voulu
promouvoir
c'est à dire que je vous avais demandé
en fait voilà je vous avais demandé de
rencontrer quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissiez pas oui moi je dis moi je
veux pas tellement envie de parler à
neurologue j'aimerais mais par les
métiers mais messi de nom de entendons
nous précisons bien le jeu
il ya beaucoup de gens qui m'intéressent
avait avec lesquels le j'adorerais que
ce soit 2,2 de grands journalistes de
deux de grands politiques de dd
des gens de deux justices des médecins
oui bien sûr j'adore pas les rencontrer
être là être être invitée avec eux les
écouter leur poser des questions mais je
veux dire découvrir quelqu'un qu'on
admire pour une raison ou pour une autre
comme ça
sur un canapé c'est un peu c'est un peu
faux joue la corde oui il ya un contact
on ne se lance pas la tête des gens il
ya de faux rapports alors là vous avez
préféré mais par les métiers alors qu'un
je préfère parler avec avec une personne
que je connais et qui finalement est des
notions ses voisines des deux politiques
de baroé
de sécurité de sécurité sociale ou de
médecine alors on va lui demander de
venir
c'est un très très très très gentil
garçon enfin très très gentil garçon ou
alors vous êtes vous essayer à côté
bonjour bonjour comment ça mon série
bozouls commencé
voilà norgil je vais commencer au moins
barbie parce que tu n'étais pas là bas
mais si nous sommes audités voilà alors
que la caméra est un gros plan
maintenant si vous me michel serrault
bien sûr il des idées idées neuves de
que vous l'ayez demandé dans votre
émission samassa le surprend tout le
monde vous savez c'est une idée oui
c'est une idée mais j'aime bien parler
avec michel et je sais bien encore des
choses à vous de genève mme bah oui mais
bien sûr oui oui ou non on n'aura pas le
temps de tout
pouvoir dire non de toute façon que sur
certains sujets qu'on ne va pas pouvoir
aborder dans moi j'aime j'aime bien
parler avec michel parce que c'est parce
que c'est un homme avec lequel je peux
parler de tout ce qui est intéressant de
métier ce qui est intéressant plus
sérieusement c'est qu'on a toujours
l'impression que ces duos et des duos
qui se prolonge par le ps que le succès
de qui se prolonge et que c'est presque
autant ddd duo d'intérêt que d'amitié
ans dans votre cas c'est vraiment de
l'amitié vous êtes vraiment amis est lié
je vous en prie mon cher que vous
appelez profession
mérité mais que sa vie c'est on va
s'appeler professeurs maîtres dont
bajeux je crois vous savez que c'est
comme c'est comme dans comme dans un
couple comme dans un ménage là une
question d'intérêt quand on parle
d'intérêts il ya toujours il ya toujours
un intérêt sordide eux je veux dire si
on est ensemble si on fait ça vire
ensemble ou si on fait une partie de sa
vie professionnelle ensemble c'est parce
que
on a un intérêt un intérêt mais dans le
sens de la vie en commun c'est à dire
qu'on s'intéresse aux mêmes choses on
s'intéresse aux mêmes formes au même en
l'occurrence aux mêmes formes d'humour
ou même une forme de comics et puis je
crois que nous ne nous sommes jamais
saturé l'un l'autre nous n'avons jamais
trop empiéter sur nos vies sur nos vies
d'hommes à à l'un et à l'autre et puis
très vite nous nous sommes
séparés pour jouer pour jouer michel
d'un côté moi donner l'impression que
votre association elle a duré tellement
d'années mais finalement ça fait
longtemps que vous jouez séparément
aussi mais nous on a joué souvent
séparés on était toujours ensemble ou au
cabaret au théâtre
enfin je veux dire pendant très très
longtemps on sait pas qui tu es et
finalement mais on était effectivement
peut-être gens je vois une pièce par un
an que tu as joué fleurs de cactus je
jouais monsieur blon là et on se
retrouvait le soir donc ça fait très
longtemps qu'on ne se quittent pas nous
bien entendu un côté la cage aux folles
vous avez joué quatre enfants nous
sommes retrouvés nous avions joué
auparavant à vaudeville anglais qui
s'appelle vison voyageur nous sommes
retrouvés là et puis bon michel michel a
fait du cinéma belge a tourné et puis
que nous sommes retrouvés pour la cage
aux folles est à nouveau là
j'ai créé une pièce un bon vous
expliquer si vous serez déjà leader pour
michel pour moi pour moi je ne sais pas
où ça va ya toujours le problème quand
on est qu'il ya toujours le problème des
d'équilibré des rôles de trouver de
trouver là
sa peinture est jamais eu de rivalité
entre vous honnêtement que ça à écouter
ces quarts de finale est la plus grande
rivalité ne va pas parler de d'années
parce que ça fait quelques années mais
si on avait eu je crois y en aurait eu
au bout du bout de trois mois oui
collaboration et à leurs jours disait
par exemple qu' il ya des affinités et
en même temps je crois que c'est très
important ça en même temps qu on fait
notre métier de comédien le temps passé
nous vivons comme nous sommes des gens
le disaient des gens quand même très
près du métier bien sûr cette notre vie
et je veux dire que vous comprenez que
en même temps si on ne s'entendait pas
bien s'ils avaient pas quand même entre
nous une grande amitié dire ça serait il
se serait pas possible parce que ce qui
est important c'est de le temps passe
nous vivons je dire de
nous le temps notre vie en même temps qu
on fait ce métier on fait par son métier
bon on va pas se dire on va faire son
métier pendant 30 ans et on va vivre
trente ans n'est ce pas en attendant ce
qu'on a tendance au au début d'une
carrière attention ces jeux le
s'inscrire rien il ya un équilibre à
trouver justement entre le travail et
puis les gens qui est con qu'on
rencontre c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
la vie vous ressenti la même manière
j'allume mon mais sur les réticences
possible le président anti alors avec
jean ça fait quelques années quelques
mois qu'on travaille en son nom mais
vous êtes d'accord sur les événements du
monde surveille jugement je vous connais
vous pensé la même chose profondément
oui bien sûr oui bien sûr parce que vous
soyez vous savez il ya cette chose
fondamentale dans un disons disons pas
duo dans une association dans toutes les
associations pour moi le critère
c'est de ne pas avoir à aller au bout
presque d'une phrase au bout d'une idée
pour être compris par son partenaire
jamais jamais nous avons travaillé
ensemble nous écrivions ensemble dans
les séances de travail jamais il est
arrivé à michel jamais il m'est arrivé à
moi de dire et donc j'ai pas compris ce
que l'expriment une idée de et et ça ça
dépasse notre cadre ce qui fait qu'il ya
effectivement un petit groupe de
personnes avec les avec lequel
nous aimons nous retrouver nous aimons
être sont des personnes il faut
travailler dans ce métier sur la même
longueur d'onde alors on parle on parle
de chapelles quand on veut être
déplaisant mais pas du tout c'est la
même longueur d'onde parce qu'il faut il
faut ne pas avoir à expliquer aux gens
il faut il faut être surtout dans le
comique même longueur d'onde croire dans
le métier mais aussi sur le reste de la
vie vous savez je concède en sachant
qu'ils seront d'un coup l'expiration des
ddd numéro qu'on pouvait avoir ça
ressemblait à des choses qu'on sentait
de la même manière et de jouer la
comédie vous savez je pense que comme
par exemple quand on va jouer les
comédiens je pense je dis moi comment tu
joues et je te dirai qui tu es oui je
pense que ça se voit à voyez il ya des
familles de gens alors il ya c'est un
tout vous avez les mêmes opinions
politiques je voulais qu'elle
nourrit son site helmand
toujours sur le plan humain oui oui et
oui absolument absolument absolument bas
parce que je pense je pense qu'il y a
des options qui sont une grande option
et puis après il ya le
ca se ventile avec des nuances je n'en
avais pas comment vous ventilé vous avez
déjà joué des deux mois je voudrais dire
une chose très importante c'est qu'on
parlait de collaboration de travaillant
comme les gens disaient il n'a pas
besoin de s'expliquer et le plus
difficile dans ce métier c'est pour
faire passer évidemment réside surtout
dans le comique jean a raison de faire
passer des idées ou des gags vous voyez
eux si on doit s'expliquer c'est pas
possible il une chose très importante
aussi c'est quand on travaille à 2 je le
vois moi par exemple quand on me fait
lire un scénario
quand les c'est très difficile de
travailler à deux je veux dire il faut
pas venir aux critiques il faut venir
écouter ce que l'autre dit et si
possible l'enrichir mais ne pas
systématiquement écouter l'autre n'est
ce pas moi je vois des choses on vous
dit on vous amène une pièce on vous
amène un scénario et j'entends des gens
dire il est très bien mais il faudrait
changer l'histoire une histoire de
travail les gens ne travaillent pas sur
ce qu'on leur propose ils sont tout de
suite à côté et pour faire briller leurs
idées c'est pas ça la collaboration dans
dans mon avis dans maintenant c'est
d'essayer de comprendre ce que je m'en
explique et comment ça peut abou dhabi
élémentaire et complémentaires et alors
ça je trouve que alors c'est aussi bien
avec un auteur c'est aussi bien avec des
partenaires avec des comédiens et c'est
aussi bien aussi avec un metteur en
scène hélas
c'est pour ça que je vais vous parliez
tout à l'heure de dire vous ne vous êtes
jamais trouvé en rivalité
pas du tout justement parce que je crois
je crois que nous sommes nous sommes
complémentaires pourraient vous n'avez
jamais eu envie de fonder une compagnie
tous les deux on nous a demandé je crois
oui plusieurs fois oui oui oui il a
demandé de le renier notre compagnie
quand même nous sommes des gens de bonne
compagnie d'ailleurs que vous pouvez
peut-être en juger
[Musique]